among his many politicians he's the
author of shifting the color white race
and very fulfilling career state and
also shaping race policy united states
with comparative perspective which is
particularly relevant today special as
it compare the second france US and
england on a policy of integration of
minorities desk i'm going to introduce
weekly ad result amor analysts or we
started then we'll go in order and each
plus we pay us to be for about 20
minutes and then we'll snap some time
whatever for preference so our first con
paper is mine
great citizens in grade school jobs
papers called ugly monkey ghetto his
friends have an american-style baseball
second try media writing at least 10
girl who's a sociology department
Marquette University her papers called
visualizing wisdoms in the United States
third we have halogen era from Paris his
papers called generations of Africans in
france between visiting skin color and
religion and finally plethora of venome
cameo from a university of montreal her
papers called the racialization
so I'm going to my paper gives recently
migration and there are in French and as
a country from Senegal many would
attorney they have the first my
confidence and today yet an important
part of that it's another phase of Islam
in France less documented in this
decision of silicon migration and it's
at for ha visto en el Francois mosh well
characterized as an old migration
through that expression the understand
the quatrain Ferrari migration are kept
the characteristic of play whatever
violation that is soon to say that they
have the style of continuing the
tradition and that they maintain the
Sunni distinction the student
registration express itself in my
opinion so to adapt winner associate
affect the Sunni a language and Islam
the space of this is to repeal the
saloon gate productivity department on a
particular
graphy the center is at first one back
to the original village couldn't really
tell Cara and immigration or just for
her that were present the space of
discussion coded by showing in good name
literally to the bookshop in the
greeting tex engine on the day of a lead
the sacrifice of Abraham which is
consuming gave the end of the year
Richard Pryor and greeting is to be
current true that is to die on the whole
soul Cara and not far away from the very
beginning of my work also negate
migration I have cookies read on the
confusion of identity in the world of
religion and paid particular attention
to the similarity of missing Africans in
an intellectual and institutional the
space where they have limited visibility
at such I have been in eagle workers
residential another through my very
observant
German the fact that appear to be
vulnerable when sunita workers
identified herself negatively they
carded to emphasize ethnicity the Sunni
cable which could be translated solution
in PT the salinity of black color
in our bloodstream and when's a definite
that sell a positively the malady that
their self by hitting frost they're
being Muslim this to face was thus
consecrated one as the positive pole and
the other of the negative pole and
migration swimming a community's
preserve the lemon and the cetacean
political conspiracy religious
aristocracy artisanal taste dissident of
slaves as well as the elder Yahoo's use
of eruption and further the negative
petition of the self is just recently
dependent on resistance in their midst
of social status and that your source of
conflict totalitarianism and inequality
well the rejection of this practice are
exercised by and watching the principle
of equality of being
before the exam and secondly sue
democratic values and the river ecology
this type of dissidence displays the
center of gravity of the group to other
EG build upon scences the most is named
the silent identity reflect fairly
netley into the vernacular construction
of the attestation from french society
in fact Sunita migrants are not always
as pivot in the African bestest friend
his feet in the water versus bloodstream
their detention has more people with the
opposition of hazara it mean Nazareth
and Muslim means Muslim they oppose
silicon position to France imaginative
society which is registered to sell Oh
mr. and Tasha thus preserve the activity
ger- an African collision us some time
the case of the earth nalini singh group
at a city I reckon security in and bike
slam and Nick commercial flight maxima
bursary identity or at least his
internal internal side is less uncovered
in the color black as in slap both as
much in palo alto slap and when they
identified by ethnicity in charge it
filling it with Islam
that you to sing in army that reaches
singularly identify students llama is
its fragmented energy it is Islam that I
have infinite as segmented Islam as
opposite brother Han aslam like
Brotherhood as is immunity this segment
Islam is s clippers poor little visible
in the beginning absolutely worker
migration in the 50 60 but later appeal
implanted into the community of workers
and starting in the mid 70 has
progressively after men itself in the
city and the culture to which African
family more religious education take a
particular dimension in the frontal
cortex of the sheriff a disaster
associated as non-muslim as the
religious minority and and also an
ethnic minority molarity equals raised
nipples polity attention to reimagine
they are identity in the furniture
context they were Brown the religious /
the ethnic working with the Association
movement and the activists movement for
the promotion of Sony culture and
language I have been in touch directly
with the strategy of immigrants balance
of y'all's Board of Immigration and of
aesthetician school social work has
until
etc my perception is that involve their
identity Constitution Islam takes a
central place the villain most engaged
in the production of Sony tech culture
didn't verbally importance to Islam was
essential for the promotion of sunita
language in the country of origin or in
other country of migration like Egypt
are also strongly mobilized mobilized
for the translating into silicon secure
the text of Islam for them sisters are
considered as an aspect of their culture
cultural and linguistic editor with the
passaggio writer killed you must
integrate as much as focus on stories
and Logano por alla Tory MPs Maxim and
product in this screen the association
of sonic a student in Cairo Egypt has
taken significant st in translating text
of the Quran and leadership and villain
well soon see an internal collects oven
in friendship once the Association for
the promotion of the pseudonym language
proposal to parent objection the Sunni
pelham Atlanta stood in the history of
Italian parents responded as follow what
you say is very good it's a children to
know their maternal language it would be
Goodson whoever for us the most
important matter which is also
problematic if how to make it so that
resists even know the basis of the Quran
Talmud adding a practice a religion in
the distinction of the earth situation
immigrants have experiences the
recomposition that may is so Z say the
farm of building which used to be
Buzzard on local initiative have been
relegated to the background in order to
emphasize and drove them back to the
center as it is the real source of the
split between us and z intervention
intervention san fran in western Africa
African cities France the United sell
the education of children born outside
sunningdale country has offered me a
question to which faridi are trying to
bring an dungeon confronted is a strong
migration without the brain is a country
of origin Damaso strategy
developer maria assunta woman who
demands and electric is their children
or follow their husband in the case of
mix opinion that the death of children
not happy in central Africa or Europe is
the beginning of immigration children
who are sent is a pattern our country of
origin for pretty sure far from being a
cooling into action of immigration the
faucet settling this return to the
country of origin have a function of
socialization and and almost always is
the duty pattern after sub years for the
Sunni a destra in France and more
generally in Europe and in the u.s. we
observe a progressive emergence of new
cities of very personal concern in
particular was a religious education of
children sense is a transnational
ization of their negative space to the
globalization of the X lab and to the
circulation of new religious it between
the country of collision the a balsamic
world ends a lot now I'm going to speak
about the naturalization and does not
see reason masculinization
sunita Slama in France of the defense
engages kaha in Africa grupo de Vaca
Monica in Europe and in the US the world
in furniture is the most important and
constitute the four of convergence of
air circulation in transnational sees
this position past systematically be
expected divisive famous encode those
who from France to attempt to live in a
nation modification the transformation
of the village the first initiative of
the Descolada with regard to their
native country have been the building of
the rest all the restoration of village
Muslim in the 60 and the 70 through this
quality because to this just for how in
particular is the excellent aristocracy
being in lower position than the elder
of the village world competition with
and fighting over leadership of the
Milky local village community something
which has been less ethical whoever
amici considered an ongoing phenomena is
affirmation and circulation of the
silicon religious being imitated in
horrible Muslim culture in their country
of origin senegal money mutiny and then
in the other Arab countries
mirakkel Helia Saudi sister has played a
major role in race relations in the
context of settlement of the
establishment of a family and the
prediction of the second generation the
singularity of the spirits is to have
lunch from the beginning of the
seventeenth the movement of racism is as
shown in the birth of the immigrant
significant reduction and thus to have a
civil possible and necessary the
islamization of the French land with the
majority of Sunni tasty beer and spasm
previously considered alone is eluted
Baraka the battle and works love could
not flush having Erica in France as we
enter poor girls like their countrymen
in the most attractive space of the area
of discussion this editor very quickly
discovered the stronger demand that
expresses themselves in the herd of
innovation in full transformation and
full racialization a former factories in
status from that happens that I open it
when Toby that are illegal to be done
not only in the beginning exactly in
France this clarissa have pre very
developer their service to the Sunni
take a miracle for linguistic reason kuz
salman and child health in community or
for applicant families and tell such as
islamic rebel the young man's muslim
ummah also they participate in
globalization in that they are migratory
paths and the circulation takes them
across several space the army sleep
practice are strongly rooted to the
Sunni people the Mekong workers claim is
far from being a perfect tablet edition
edit half their religious activity to
hand in hand with eliminated activity in
the sector personal for this kingdom for
example they work in the service
industry 3d and tested totally taking
advantage of locally in the chemical
workers community Oh in the neighborhood
the association they teach cheap booze
and the Quran and teach Arabic to the
Midland cheaper in France so the parents
who choose to send that you learn to
their country of collision the strong
conviction of mentioning the parison is
certain knowledge of sunita leaders
you'd say their children thus young
people showing themselves the pregnant
on how often in Santa back to the blend
young woman our token sanction there
in the two case since their kids are
under general a temporary and the
parents fertilizing they are important
difference after so many years which
should allow the children to grow up as
real oh good sudden k people since
theremin phenomenon cover tune to the
country for the social culture of course
an implication of kikyo as did more or
less describe it and we will not to
interfere with corner we would like to
pull additional to the sending of young
adolescent not for the purpose of
correction of a being given back to the
right part but with the aim of educating
than an athlete result in religious
matter certainly the difference between
those two objective is very strong I try
to give you some example of the children
that I entered we go they are each Mary
but i think i have not
time so I'm going
if you guess one example Mumma is the
youngest daughter of Sunni American
family of the threesome and Sri Buddhism
upset by the religious position of the
two elder daughter who have left Islam
for another faith and were both murdered
two Frenchmen the parents and her anchor
three brother to Bamako the Sun
administered in a French middle school
and high school and she is in the Arab
Islamic school after nine years of age
they are put up in the house of blues
close relative at the end of three years
they come back to France the eldest girl
is Santa to Pakistan to finish her
education in a colony schoolin after
pakistan ship of silver education in
malaysia because of our answer fans that
Pakistan is preventive from the point of
view of language today she is money and
into assuming he becomes in the youth
and spend the time between the trees the
country
incomplete Jonah as I have already
worked out of the factor of such a
distinction for the suitcase llama
everyday is reportedly a test resistant
among no work and says that they have
converted the Sunni Islam was speaking
of young people who have been regulated
in soon in the country they say now this
is too soon even his sleep the language
well and he played in the molarity per
lesson just as they are minorities
infraction having the option of early
education or authentication infirmity in
religious nagoo in their country of
origin they can pursue immigration /
longer period without fear of losing I
don t systematically despite the space
in their country of punishing the
dissonance of this children remain died
immigration the most valuable space such
as a country to the north hence their
participation in transnational Muslim
network such as the carrier of adam4adam
soon in case for our come to put on
religious Brotherhood to make possible
the Queen occasion and separation
in very wide areas which correspond to
the face of the earth Escobar the
community market are on offer here the
opportunity this is the performance
between competent personnel of course a
customer to the countries of the north
to which people the migr and
simplicity is la MOLLE in the eyes of
the knee position mr. enforcer there are
entities in the society that we save
them some children integration to
religious record and God both girl and
power in their own communities in being
as well to fulfill the need for
indigenous religious person
try to come to a way to compare to
contact about me actually I think on
virgin so what I can do is give you some
kind of introductory comments of rather
contextual kind starting with Europe
rather than friends in order to do what
French unit so by saying that French is
in that matter is not exceptional mood
so in Europe is happening in French is
quite symmetrical to what's happening as
well and by saying that I will drop you
some images I photos to describe say so
after this introduction i will first and
we have three part they did to barton
and concluding remarks
what I wouldn't do is first draw a kind
of rough map of the current discussion
that are surrounding diversity diversity
and national identity discussion and and
here are some of it is religious who is
like a train in the first favorite I
don't think that friend is looking at
the states and as far as race and racial
relations of example but diversity has
been directly imported as a topic and
add a level from the American in the
political distance didn't part without
stopping the second I shall come back on
the place of religion in this reflection
thinking about French diversity and
further my completely martyr will come
to this idea of the racialization of
Muslims and friends as my argument being
that this presentation as I see
happening at the process of Muslims and
friends is both the outcome of on the
one hand a quiet long-standing
historical perspective on Republicans
not only to worship Allah unrecognized
and second a lost an outcome of the
specific regulation of the conversations
that is actually being home between
Muslim
I look at the way conversation and
interaction succeed they will not
insensitive surroundings so that's my my
ancient man of my dreams the general
content when talking about I said I
start with these two pictures we know
that things are quite illustrative of
what I call again following a very
classical society called vector which is
meals who wrote in 26 so it's not the
last one published something interesting
on Muslims in Europe but I think he says
it tells us quite interesting stuff in
terms of both on the way the
conversation should be should be holding
in the contemporary society as far as
difference and diversity and use the
word ordinary track and I think in the
European Union context in almost all
Member States we actually fixing on a
daily basis and the New York types of
yesterday made a very very interesting
article on the Belgian situation which
is the last last development story
finding out that we're going to answer a
banner with a full bag of the full dance
card also in Belgium the Parliament
still has to be edition so answer we are
facing in Europe this is ordinary from
that is made of leading capacity to
relate to differences and to connect
what is a big issue integral ism
radicalization political Islam and small
additive excited problems today we went
in we embedded in and we are facing and
we think about all we are raking leaves
that shouldn't meet me or we are
difficult to make to give minutes to
what happens and I think these two
pictures are quite interesting because
they are respecting the way we talk in
Europe about our Muslim co-citizens so
here you see the the Swiss flag that is
rotting black milkshake minarets
alongside a woman that is the wearing
the cap is all too well and on the other
picture you so lose your woman should
actually in Australia this one but this
is a big the competing what we called a
bikini in Europe last summer which is
this two-piece bus coming soon that was
the argument of a huge controversy both
in Italy particularly North Italy where
they are not so many bitches there are
some cookies but it swimming pool
swimming pools and also a friends in the
southern part of the country so why do I
start with these two pictures just to
give you an idea off of this panic about
on the one hand multiculturalism I think
online and on the other hand integration
Republican intuition having cell I've
been spreading in the European country
of the last agility and I think what is
interesting here is that situations that
are occurring in one companies are very
quickly made a reality in another
complex that has as our lives rightly
pointed out this money
tradition completely open public
cultures as far as religion and
stagnation sequences so one of the most
interesting question i think for me it
or would be how come are these divergent
tradition how come are these diverging
models of citizenship really producing
this Europeanized discourse of
fertilization office and now I shall
come to my first one I'd like to thank
the keeper what wonderful people to do
about these stupid job just the one year
is to begin first of all just after the
the sis rotation on minerals one month
after then association to position
ourselves strasburg project launched a
context of most beautiful minaret of
friends so people are taking pictures
over grants and sending you know and
there is a chewy who will be the most
people I think that is kind of enjoyed
the evening breeze
about this routine and what each was
serving I remember last year in a
delight there were huge debate in the
rescue corporation of other like Beach
about people kingdom it's not so rose
now sorry either their presence of
Muslims terrorists on cooperation and
just first question you just take a few
words about my nose 7pm we're sharing
personal demo acting friends president
is applied so as you said for the
continental brands there are all
invincible and we can be certain process
principles not a revision up for
Catholicism to drive but for other
territories you have some comment so I I
knew about the content
what is this striking in the not
supporting the night side as well as
pointed out this morning by today is
that there is always a pragmatic
perception of how those principles nodes
are violently time and and concealed and
there are normative expectations that
are discourses I'd probably be wishing
there's more trouble that when an
embedded is more troubles as a local
thanks you're entitled to the local
situation to you as you want to see your
surroundings so I don't have any
specific things to tell about my life in
this framework the issue here is really
to look at the way while admittedly race
in the French hunters are they step
forbidden forbidden lame although they
have been given they are being even
reality by the way Muslims are not
targets the physic families who are you
operating in their own way to litigate
two experiments discrimination and not
feel I sufficiently trustful in in the
public institution for instance to
denounce sets of all that all that
conservation
presentations all day this one
particularly convocation ization lessons
and United States and I wonder if you
looked at racialization of the Muslim
bring sub-sahara Africa to go again to
see what's going on here because it's
believed by many particularly
african-americans that its fist ratio
opening of color plane and with the air
to a lighter taking over from the docks
and acronyms and that it was related
problem and discussing this in our
communities and the other things on our
duty l was
one about 2 years ago he was killed and
bronze and was shot 16 times will shine
41 times and I was shocked that he
didn't his family didn't seem to get
support of the law of Muslim community
and his family what the Al Sharpton and
usually immigrants stuck what happened
it's due back from there until we get
shot if something happens and then they
go and I went up to the upon and reason
I think everybody is probably too young
to remember that but it was a news item
at that time I went up to the apartment
where it happened and I see the bullet
holes myself and they shot at him for
one time he shot in 16 times and they
said that going to wallet and he wasn't
there and the other people who
there were the cops who shine and they
all walked and I used to dabble in
journalism so I knew the questions to
ask the neighbors nobody else asks the
neighbors that they heard anything a
neighbor told me that all they heard was
shots and they would describe the same
way they were described in the
newspapers you know what the natives but
nobody interviewed them now to me ever
to do who was from other New Guinea
birthday was shot because it was flat
not accustomed to Muslim which brings me
to something else I be curious to go
whether Africans of our applicants have
been harassed war since Christmas last
year with the underwear long
ballin whether they dress more because
of that then they were with me 911 I
think the olive complexion Arabs would
have been harassed more after nine
eleven a dogskin African not in Muslim
where is an active in there and problems
on that basis and I'm curious to know
whether in this country now they are
having more problems they something
black blue mussel and we have a question
I wanted to direct it was that I didn't
get the full sentence wet dog I didn't
get the part because that African
Americans do not experience upward
mobility I guess until civil rights
movement is energy same theory that was
used to explain the absence of such
economic
overall since slavery until now one the
theory culture body was developed in
like nineteen sixty-three to explain why
african-americans had not achieved no
less debt so a special theory was
developed for them that was my point
well because I was going to say
experience of an ability if otherwise in
Dalston cotton you know it was just
about that that we have theories to
explain human behavior but for
african-americans they came up with a
special theory at this point why don't
we there are other question why don't we
collect a few questions and then give
the palace the less work deputies just a
retard dr. paper I mean I appreciated
your you theorized ation but it's
efficient
raishin Muslims having done a lot of
research on encounters and
discrimination but I think we have to be
careful when we talk about actions by
the government versus public discourse
generalizations and stereotypes what
example you mentioned the burden of
immigration I I did research on post
9-11 naturalization of people from
Muslim majority countries forbidden
areas of the world that are heavily
populated by Muslims and I kind that
actually the number of people
naturalized in the seven years after
9-11 was larger than the network people
naturalized in the seven years before
not another so when it comes to
government actions I don't think you
need a pattern of incidence to for the
government to take to take certain
precautions but when you want to make
generalizations as you pointed out and
I'm not
away from a few from your existed
extending types can be very damaging we
just generalized that without that the
company has a some of this is your 10
there are number of pieces of delays in
rotation
there are many court cases about this
and I would suspect that nonetheless
naturalizations would increase in
democratic so and I don't have any data
on sub-saharan African since Christmas
but I would suspect that that is going
to castro and then with the Moscow that
women I expected
or
assistant historic this is hazardous to
historic another reason structural
reasons economic reasons has brought
from our pictures but we will
Islanders that there is a growing
interest in race and identity diplomatic
experience from the children of examples
this has a lot to do the original arrest
the Pakistani we have returned to Saul
into the experience or side of it
there's an interesting campaign taking
place now being led by students from UC
Santa Barbara mostly I ops team is
pushing for a minority status in the
census pushing for through the new
category border and probably recent talk
about this more like a historic event
Americans have long been categorizes
right now you getting these new
communities the younger generation
that's pushing for it differently
and this has to do with changing
demographics new new immigrants earlier
events team from the performance
you